Quiero comenzar con una historia, a la Seth Godin,
de cuando yo tenía 12 años de edad.
Mi tio Ed me regaló un suéter azul hermoso --
al menos yo pensaba que era hermoso.
Tenía unas zebras borrosas caminando a lo largo del estómago,
y el Monte Kilimanjaro y el Monte Meru estaban como
justo a lo largo del pecho, también borrosos.
Y yo me lo ponía cada vez que podía,
pensando que era lo más fabuloso que poseía.
Hasta un día en noveno grado,
cuando estaba con algunos jugadores de fútbol.
Y mi cuerpo claramente había cambiado, y Matt Mussolina,
que era indiscutiblemente mi némesis en bachillerato,
dijo con voz atronadora que
ya no teníamos que ir lejos a hacer paseos en esquí,
sino que todos podíamos esquiar en el Monte Novogratz.
(Risas)
Y yo estaba tan humillada y mortificada
que inmediatamente corrí a casa y regañé a mi madre
por haberme dejado jamás usar ese horrible suéter.
Conducimos al centro de caridad Goodwill y botamos el suéter
de manera un tanto ceremoniosa,
con la idea de que nunca tendría que pensar más en el suéter
ni verlo de nuevo.
Avance rápido -- 11 años después, soy una chica de 25 años de edad.
Estoy trabajando en Kigali, Ruanda, trotando por las laderas empinadas,
cuando veo, 3 metros frente mío, a un pequeño niño -- de 11 años --
corriendo hacia mi, usando mi suéter.
Y yo pensando, no, esto no es posible.
Pero entonces, curiosa, corro hasta el chico -- claro
pegándole tremendo susto --
lo agarro por el cuello del suéter, le doy la vuelta, y ahí está mi nombre
escrito en el cuello del suéter.
Cuento esa historia, porque me ha servido y sigue sirviéndome
como una metáfora sobre el nivel de conexión
que todos tenemos en esta Tierra.
A menudo no nos percatamos de lo que nuestra acción e inacción
le hace a la gente que pensamos que jamás veremos o conoceremos.
También la cuento porque relata una historia contextual más grande
sobre lo que es la ayuda y lo que puede ser.
Que esto haya viajado al centro de caridad Goodwill en Virginia,
y se haya movido hasta caer en la industria mayor,
que en ese punto estaba dando millones de toneladas de ropa de segunda a África y Asia.
Lo cual era muy bueno, proveyendo ropa barata.
Al mismo tiempo, ciertamente en Ruanda,
eso destruyó la industria local de menudeo.
No por decir que no ha debido hacerlo,
sino que tenemos que mejorar en responder a las preguntas
que deben ser consideradas cuando pensamos en consecuencias
y respuestas.
Entonces, voy a seguir con Ruanda, alrededor de 1985, 1986,
donde yo estaba haciendo dos cosas.
Había comenzado una pastelería con 20 madres solteras.
Nos llamaban las Osas de las Malas Nuevas, y nuestra noción era que
íbamos a coronar el negocio de las golosinas en Kigali,
lo cual no era difícil porque no había golosinas antes de que llegaramos nosotras.
Y porque teníamos un buen modelo de negocio, realmente lo logramos,
y vi cómo esas mujeres se transformaron a nivel micro.
Pero al mismo tiempo, comencé un banco de micro-finanzas,
y mañana Iqbal Quadir va a hablar sobre Grameen,
que es el abuelo de los bancos de micro-finanzas,
lo cual es ahora un movimiento mundial -- ustedes hablan de un meme --
pero entonces era algo muy nuevo, especialmente en una economía
que pasaba del trueque al comercio.
Acertamos en muchas cosas.
Nos enfocamos en un modelo de negocio, insistimos en meterle carne al juego.
Las mujeres tomaban sus propias decisiones al final del día
sobre cómo iban a usar su acceso al crédito
para construir sus pequeños negocios, ganar más ingresos
para poder cuidar mejor de sus familias.
Lo que no entendíamos, lo que estaba pasando todo a nuestro alrededor,
con la confluencia del miedo, la lucha étnica
y ciertamente un juego de ayuda, si quieren, que estaba jugando en
ese movimiento invisible pero ciertamente palpable dentro de Ruanda,
que en ese tiempo, 30 por ciento del presupuesto era todo ayuda externa.
El genocidio ocurrió en 1994,
siete años después de que todas estas mujeres trabajaran juntas
para construir este sueño.
Y la buena noticia fue que la institución,
la institución bancaria, perduró.
De hecho, se convirtió en el mayor prestamista de rehabilitación en el país.
La pastelería fue completamente arrasada,
pero las lecciones para mí fueron que la rendición de cuentas cuenta --
que hay que construir las cosas con la gente en la tierra,
usando modelos de negocios donde, como diría Steven Levitt,
los incentivos importan.
Entendamos que, por muy complejos que seamos, los incentivos importan.
Así que cuando Chris me planteó qué tan maravilloso todo
lo que estaba pasando en el mundo,
que estábamos viendo un cambio en el zeitgeist,
por un lado estoy absolutamente de acuerdo con él,
y estaba tan emocionada de ver lo que pasó con el G8 --
que el mundo, por gente como Tony Blair y Bono
y Bob Geldof -- el mundo está hablando de la pobreza global,
el mundo está hablando de Africa
de maneras que yo jamás en mi vida había visto.
Es emocionante.
Y al mismo tiempo, lo que me mantiene despirerta en la noche
es el temor a que veamos las victorias del G8 --
50 billones de dólares de incremento en la ayuda a Africa,
40 billones de dólares en reducción de deuda -- como una victoria,
como más que el capítulo uno, como nuestra absolución moral.
Y de hecho, lo que tenemos que hacer es verlo como el capítulo uno,
celebrarlo, cerrarlo, y reconocer que necesitamos un capítulo dos
que es todo sobre ejecución -- todo sobre el cómo-hacer.
Y si hay sólo una cosa que vayan a recordar sobre lo que quiero decir hoy,
debe ser que la única manera de acabar con la pobreza, de hacerla historia,
es creando sistemas viables en la tierra
que entreguen bienes y servicios críticos asequibles a los pobres,
de formas que sean sustentables y escalables.
Si hacemos eso, realmente podremos hacer de la pobreza historia.
Y fue eso -- toda esa filosofía --
lo que me alentó a comenzar mi esfuerzo actual
llamado el Fondo Acumen,
que está intentando crear algunos mini-planos
sobre cómo hacer eso en agua, salud y vivieda
en Pakistan, India, Kenya, Tanzanía y Egipto.
Y quería hablar un poco sobre eso, y algunos de los ejemplos
para que puedan ver qué es lo que estamos haciendo.
Pero antes -- y esta es otra de mis quejas --
Quiero hablar un poco sobre quiénes son los pobres.
Porque muy frecuentemente hablamos de ellos como estas
duras, enormes masas de gente que ansían ser libres
cuando en realidad, es una historia bastante sorprendente.
A nivel macro, cuatro billones de personas en la Tierra ganan menos de cuatro dólares diarios.
Es de ellos de quien hablamos cuando pensamos en los pobres.
Si lo suman, es la tercera economía más grande en la Tierra,
y aún así la mayor parte de estas personas es invisible.
Donde trabajamos típicamente, hay personas ganando entre
uno y tres dólares diarios.
Quiénes son estas personas?
Son agricultores y trabajadores fabriles.
Trabajan en oficinas del gobierno. Son choferes.
Son empleadas domésticas.
Típicamente pagan por bienes y servicios críticos como agua,
como salud, como vivienda, y pagan 30 o 40 veces
lo que sus contrapartes de clase media pagan --
ciertamente donde trabajamos en Karachi y Nairobi.
Los pobres también quieren tomar, y toman, decisiones inteligentes,
si uno les da esa oportunidad.
Entonces, dos ejemplos.
Uno es en la India, donde hay 240 millones de agricultores,
la mayoría de los cuales gana menos de dos dólares diarios.
Donde trabajamos en Aurangabad, la tierra es extraordinariamente seca.
Uno ve a la gente ganando en promedio de 60 centavos a un dólar.
Este tipo de rosado es un emprendedor social llamado Ami Tabar.
Lo que hizo fue ver qué estaba pasando en Israel, estrategias más amplias,
y averiguar cómo funciona el riego por goteo,
que es una manera de traer agua directamente hasta las plantas.
Pero antes sólo había sido creado para fincas a gran escala,
así que Ami Tabar tomó esto y lo modularizó para un octavo de acre.
Un par de principios --
Construir en pequeño.
Hacerlo infinitamente ampliable y asequible para los pobres.
Esta familia, Sarita y su marido, compró una unidad de 15 dólares
cuando vivían en una -- literalmente una ampliación de tres paredes
con techo de hierro corrugado.
Tras una cosecha, habían aumentado su ingreso lo suficiente
para comprar un segundo sistema y completar un cuarto de acre.
Un par de años después, me encuentro con ellos.
Ahora ganan cuatro dólares diarios, lo cual es casi clase media en la India,
y me mostraron el piso de concreto que justo habían puesto
para construir su casa.
Y lo juro, uno podía ver el futuro en los ojos de esa mujer.
Algo en lo que realmente creo.
No se puede hablar de pobreza hoy sin hablar de mosquiteros contra el paludismo
y de nuevo le doy a Jeffrey Sachs de Harvard
enormes felicitaciones por traer al mundo
esta noción de su rabia -- por cinco dólares uno puede salvar una vida.
El paludismo es una enfermedad que puede matar entre uno a tres millones de personas al año.
300 a 500 millones de casos han sido reportados.
Se estima que África pierde
cerca de 13 billones de dólares al año por esta enfermedad.
Cinco dólares pueden salvar una vida.
Podemos enviar gente a la Luna, podemos ver si hay vida en Marte --
por qué no podemos darle mosquiteros de cinco dólares a 500 millones de personas?
La pregunta, sin embargo, no es por qué no podemos,
la pregunta es cómo podemos ayudarle a los africanos a hacerlo por sí mismos?
Muchos obstáculos.
Uno: la producción es muy baja. Dos: el precio es muy alto.
Tres: esta es una buena calle -- muy cerca de nuestra fábrica.
La distribución es una pesadilla, pero no es imposible.
Empezamos haciéndole un préstamo de 350,000 dólares
al productor de mosquiteros tradicionales más grande de África
para que pudieran transferir tecnología de Japón
y producir estos mosquiteros de cinco años de duración.
Acá hay solo algunas fotos de la fábrica.
Hoy, tres años después, la compañía emplea
otras mil mujeres.
Y contribuye cerca de 600,000 dólares en salarios a la economía de Tanzanía.
Es la mayor compañía de Tanzanía.
La tasa de rendimiento ahora es de 1.5 millones de redes,
tres millones para el final del año.
Esperamos tener siete millones al final del año entrante.
Así que por el lado de la producción, funciona.
Por el lado de la distribución, sin embargo,
como un mundo, tenemos mucho trabajo por hacer.
Ahora mismo, el 95% de estos mosquiteros están siendo comprados por la ONU,
y luego entregados principalmente a personas alrededor de África.
Queremos construir
sobre la base del recurso más valioso de África -- la gente.
Sus mujeres.
Y así, quiero que conozcan a Jacqueline,
mi tocaya, de 21 años de edad.
Si ella hubiera nacido en cualquier lugar excepto Tanzanía,
les digo, ella podría manejar Wall Street.
Ella maneja dos de las líneas, y ya ha ahorrado suficiente dinero
para abonar un primer pago de su casa.
Gana alrededor de dos dólares al día, está creando un fondo educacional,
y me dijo que no se va a casar ni va a tener hijos
hasta completar todo eso.
Y así, cuando le hablé de nuestra idea --
que quizás podríamos llevar un modelo Tupperware de los Estados Unidos,
y encontrar una manera para que las mujeres salieran
y vendieran estos mosquiteros a otras mujeres --
ella rápidamente comenzó a calcular cuánto podría ganar
y se apuntó.
Tomamos una lección de IDEO, una de nuestras compañías favoritas,
y rápidamente hicimos un prototipo
y llevamos a Jacqueline al área donde ella vive.
Ella juntó a 10 de las mujeres con las que interactúa
para ver si podía venderles los mosquiteros, a cinco dólares cada uno,
aún a pesar de que la gente dice que nadie los va a comprar,
y aprendimos mucho sobre cómo vender estas cosas.
No entrando con nuestras propias nociones,
porque ella no habló del paludismo sino hasta el final.
Primero, habló de comodidad, estatus, belleza.
Uno pone estos mosquiteros en el piso, dijo ella, y los insectos se van de la casa.
Los niños pueden dormir la noche entera,
la casa se ve hermosa, uno los cuelga en la ventana.
Y hemos comenzado a hacer cortinas,
y no sólo es hermoso, además la gente puede ver el estatus --
que uno cuida de sus hijos.
Sólo entonces habló de salvarle la vida a los hijos.
Muchas lecciones para aprender sobre cómo venderle
bienes y servicios a los pobres.
Quiero terminar diciendo que hay una enorme oportunidad
de hacer de la pobreza historia.
Para hacerlo bien, tenemos que crear modelos de negocios que importen,
que sean escalables y que funcionen con los africanos, indios,
y gente todo alrededor del mundo en desarrollo
que caben en esta categoria, para hacerlo por sí mismos.
Porque al final de día, de lo que se trata es de compromiso.
Se trata de entender que la gente en realidad no quiere limosnas,
que quieren tomar sus propias decisiones,
quieren resolver sus propios problemas,
y que al comprometernos con ellos,
no sólo creamos mucha más dignidad para ellos,
sino también para nosotros.
Así que les insisto a todos ustedes que la próxima vez piensen
cómo comprometerse con esta noción y esta oportunidad
que todos tenemos -- de hacer de la pobreza historia --
convirtiéndose realmente en parte del proceso
y alejándose de un mundo de nosotros-y-ellos,
y dándose cuenta que es sobre todos nosotros,
y sobre el mundo en el que nosotros, juntos, queremos vivir y compartir.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)